what's your first memory whatever it is
you're bound to cherish it the Greek
philosopher Aristotle wants called
memory the scribe of the soul meaning
that our memories are integral to our
sense of self but can we actually trust
them nothing about memory is simple for
starters we're a memory stored in which
parts of the brain hundreds of studies
have come to the same conclusion
there isn't one they're stored processed
and moved around the brain creating
complex connections across neural
networks that we still don't fully
understand the potential storage
capacity of the human brain is vast it's
not possible to quantify exactly but
estimates put it in the multi millions
of gigabytes but memory is malleable
what we remember is not necessarily what
happened a memory is not a recording
it's more like a dramatic reconstruction
and one that we can keep changing
without realizing it for any experience
to be remembered it has to be encoded
this encoding though is not any kind of
direct translation it's a rich and
complex process that creates
associations and meanings as sensory
information is encoded and also whenever
it's retrieved its interpreted in a way
that can change it and introduce errors
memory is a creative process because
unlike computers we need to be able to
make sense of the information we store
that means we're never remembering
things exactly the way they occurred we
might be remembering something very
similar but subtly modified and colored
by our own sets of associations to
people who see the same thing won't
necessarily remember the same thing and
in certain situations that's very
problematic psychologists Elizabeth
Loftus produced groundbreaking research
on eyewitness testimony her work showed
that memories can easily be influenced
even after they've been created for
example if investigators asked witnesses
a leading question about a crime such as
what color coats was he wearing their
memories may adapt to incorporate the
suggestions
similarly if two eyewitnesses confer
with each other their memories of events
often change incorporating what they've
heard from the other one but they won't
realize this has happened and witnesses
who are shown an image of someone after
a crime even if it's one of an innocent
person can sometimes paste it onto their
memory of the actual event a process
known as unconscious transference the
Innocence Project estimates that around
70% of wrongful convictions later
overturned by DNA evidence are due to
mistaken eyewitness testimony in some
cases memories can even be deliberately
created and implanted the lost in the
mall experiment took a test group of
subjects and talk to them in depth about
key childhood memories while also adding
an invented one the experience of having
been lost in a shopping center it was
found that between a quarter and a third
of subjects not only accepted this new
memory is genuine but enriched it with
specific details they created a new
memory indistinguishable from memories
of events that had actually happened
we've all possibly done the same thing
most of us have certain key memories of
being a very young child but research
suggests that they're highly unlikely to
be actual memories due to the way memory
is stored in the infant brain in many
cases we probably imagine certain scenes
at a later age when shown photos are
told stories about certain events the
subjective experience of these memories
is no different remembering childhood
events that actually happened
your precious first memory may well not
be a real memory and we're all perhaps
living in our imaginations more than we
realize
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon